Esta es yangie la ciudad más estrecha
del mundo
en el centro corre un río esta ciudad se
extiende a lo largo de 5 kilómetros y
solo tiene entre 30 y 300 metros de
ancho según el lugar
[Música]
están poblada como la cuarta ciudad de
Francia tu luz
450,000 personas viven en esta aislada
región del suroeste de China
actualmente yangie atrae a los curiosos
ya que la prensa y las redes sociales
chinas la proclamaron la ciudad más
estrecha
trabaja para la alcaldía es local conoce
cada Rincón de este lugar lo que no le
fue muy difícil
[Música]
es imposible perderse porque solo hay
una calle
[Música]
De hecho hay dos calles una a cada lado
del Río en ambas se venden
especialidades locales
pruébelo le iba a gustar Es muy rico es
una pasta de arroz dulce
le gustó
estamos en la parte antigua de la ciudad
se dice que aquí la tierra cuesta más
que el oro cada centímetro de espacio es
aprovechado al máximo mire que poco
espacio hay entre los edificios
Esto es lo que hace que el lugar sea tan
único
esta ciudad no puede crecer hacia lo
ancho Así que crece hacia el cielo qué
es lo que la hace tan conocida Buenos
días señor está preparando algo y el
señor Lee quien es chef está feliz por
la popularidad de la ciudad es bueno
para el negocio
nuestra ciudad está creciendo cada vez
tengo más clientes y el negocio va cada
vez mejor
como surgió esta ciudad incrustada entre
estas montañas Cómo se desarrolló Estas
son las preguntas que le hicimos al
historiador de la ciudad shen young
este es nuestro río Juan
imagínense lo hace 300 años
en aquella época había barcos mercantes
que navegaban por todas partes
se construyeron unos 20 muelles en la
orilla del río
y nuestros antepasados decidieron
establecerse aquí
nació Johnny
era un centro neurálgico de la región
para el transporte de bronce sal y té en
una época en la que solo se podía
transportar mercancías por el río a lo
largo de este tramo de la ruta de la
seda
[Música]
al igual que hoy los primeros habitantes
vivían en casas construidas sobre
pilotes
como el valle es estrecho y las
pendientes empinadas y engañosas los
primeros habitantes construyeron sus
cajas sobre pilotes
Esa era la mejor solución ya que era el
único terreno que había también lo
hicieron para evitar los peligros de la
subida de las aguas
las casas actuales son todas de concreto
y siguen a salvo del Río
estamos en casa de la señora yao ya
jubilada
quiere mostrarnos su lugar favorito de
su casa de cuatro pisos su terraza y
aquí no hay vecinos a la vista
siempre he vivido en esta casa mis
antepasados vivían aquí y subir
escaleras es un buen ejercicio no
viviría en ninguna otra parte
los barcos ya no navegan por este río la
ciudad vive de la agricultura y espera
desarrollar el turismo gracias a su
particular en canto